Aujourd’hui, je vais apporter plusieurs
clarifications par rapport aux deux vidéos
précédentes sur la relativité générale.
Si vous ne les avez pas vu, regardez-les.
Sinon, ce que je vais dire ne va pas avoir
beaucoup de sens…
Dans la vidéo 17, je vous avais parlé du
principe d’équivalence, et je vous ai dit
qu’il disait que la gravité et l’accélération
ne sont que les faces opposées d’une même
pièce.
Dans la vidéo 18, j’ai sous-entendu que
la gravité était la courbure de l’espace-temps.
Est-ce à dire que l’accélération est
la courbure ?
Nope.
Nope, nope, nope.
Je vous ai en fait raconté des petits mensonges
qui ont malheureusement induit mathieu da
silva en erreur.
Désolé mathieu !
D’un point de vue mathématique, accélération
et courbure sont en fait très, très distincts.
Et la clé pour comprendre la théorie d’Einstein
est, il me semble, de faire clairement la
distinction entre ces deux concepts mathématiques.
D’ailleurs on peut très bien avoir accélération
sans courbure ou courbure sans accélération.
En effet, l’espace-temps de Minkowski est
un espace-temps sans courbure, mais où il
est parfaitement possible de concevoir des
trajectoires accélérés d’objets.
Après tout, c’est ce que l’on a fait
dans le Défi Lê 2.
Et c’est ce que font à longueur de journées
les théoriciens des particules qui étudient
les forces non-gravitationnelles dans un espace-temps
sans courbure.
À l’inverse, comme je l’ai dit dans l’épisode
18, la relativité générale d’Einstein
à strictement parler exclut toutes les forces
non-gravitationnelles.
Et comme la gravité n’est pas une force,
rien ne perturbe les trajectoires des objets
à travers l’espace-temps.
Du coup, ces objets ne sont pas accélérés.
Ils vont donc en ligne droite à travers l’espace-temps.
Donc la relativité générale, c’est en
fait surtout l’étude de trajectoires sans
accélérations dans un espace-temps courbe.
D’ailleurs, on peut se demander ce qu’est
une accélération à travers l’espace-temps.
Et bien, une accélération à travers l’espace-temps,
ça correspond à une déviation de notre
trajectoire par rapport à la ligne droite
que l’on est sensé suivre.
Ici, on a par exemple la trajectoire accélérée
de Sheldon dans un espace-temps de Minkowski.
Vous voyez qu’en tout point, plutôt que
de continuer tout droit, la trajectoire de
Sheldon dévie vers la droite.
Et ce que j’ai vraiment prétendu dans l’épisode
17, c’est que nous, à la surface de la
Terre, on fait la même chose.
On incurve notre trajectoire constamment pour
nous éloigner de la ligne droite que l’espace-temps
nous dit de suivre.
J’insiste vraiment sur ce point, car de
très bons vulgarisateurs, et même des moins
comme moi, vont parfois vous dire que la courbure
de l’espace-temps courbe les lignes droites.
Ça c’est faux.
Les lignes droites dans un espace-temps sont,
par définition, des lignes droites.
C’est-à-dire pas courbe.
Ce qu’il se passe c’est que, comme pour
représenter la surface de la Terre, on utilise
en fait des espèces de cartes pour représenter
l’espace-temps de dimension 4.
Or, dans ces cartes, la représentation des
lignes droites va être courbe.
Comme c’était le cas sur la Mercator.
Mais ces lignes droites dans le vrai espace-temps,
pas dans la carte de l’espace-temps que
l’on utilise, sont vraiment droites.
Les lignes droites ne sont jamais courbes.
Par définition.
Et je vous invite vraiment à voir et revoir
les épisodes 9, 11 et 12, surtout la 11,
pour bien comprendre ça.
Thibaut Lescure trouve que j’insiste trop
sur l’absence du temps dans l’analogie
de la toile.
Je ne suis pas d’accord.
Je pense qu’elle est ultra-critique, cette
absence du temps ! Comme le dit Gabe sur PBS
Space Time, c’est la courbure du temps,
pas celle de l’espace, qui explique les
trajectoires des planètes.
Et ce n’est pas si surprenant.
Nos trajectoires en ligne droite à travers
l’espace-temps sont des trajectoires à
travers le temps et non l’espace.
Ça c’est parce que, quoiqu’on fasse,
on se déplace constamment vers le futur.
D’un point de vue mathématique, on dit
que nos trajectoires à travers l’espace-temps
sont du genre temps.
Or, la courbure que je sous-entend quand je
fais des dessins comme ceux-ci, ce sont des
courbures le long de la direction des trajectoires.
Ce sont donc des courbures dans la direction
du temps !
Thibaut rajoute que ce qui le gêne est le
fait que l’espace dans cette analogie est
2D.
Alors, oui, en effet, notre espace est en
3D.
Mais, si au lieu de considérer une toile
de dimension 2 dans un espace de dimension
3, on considérait une toile de dimension
3 dans un espace de dimension 4, dont la hauteur
dans la 4ème dimension, appelons-la ana-kata,
est ce que l’on appelle le potentiel gravitationnel.
Si on considère enfin que tout objet dans
cette toile est accéléré selon le gradient
du potentiel gravitationnel, c’est-à-dire
selon la direction de plus forte pente avec
une intensité proportionnelle à cette pente,
alors on obtient un modèle de l’univers
de dimension 5, qui, projeté dans notre espace-temps
de dimension 4 donne exactement…
la théorie de Newton ! Et c’est pour ça
que je n’aime pas cette analogie.
Elle n’a rien d’Einsteinien.
C’est une analogie newtonienne !
Alors, Jonathan, oui, certains très grands
physiciens comme Jean-Pierre Luminet, mais
aussi Brian Greene ou Kip Thorne, utilisent
malgré tout cette analogie.
Ceci dit, Luminet a très bien qu’il faut
subtilement inclure le temps et sa courbure
pour rendre l’analogie plus crédible.
Si j’ai choisi de débunker cette analogie,
ce n’est pas pour paraître plus intelligent
que ces génies.
Sérieusement, à côté de tronches comme
eux, je suis le premier des abrutis ! Si je
vous dit que l’analogie est fausse, c’est
pour vous aider à mieux comprendre le fond
de la pensée d’Einstein.
Pour y arriver, moi, ça m’a été hyper
utile d’abandonner complètement cette analogie
et de vouloir obstinément penser l’espace-temps
courbe plutôt qu’un espace courbe.
Ce qui me dérange particulièrement avec
cette analogie, c’est qu’elle nous donne
l’impression que l’on a compris.
Elle nous donne l’impression que c’est
la courbure de l’espace qui fait glisser
la pomme sur la Terre, et fait tourner la
Lune autour de la Terre.
Alors que c’est faux.
Faux.
Et archi-faux.
Ou plutôt, c’est l’explication Newtonienne.
Mais l’explication Einsteinienne est tout
autre…
Dans l’épisode 16, je vous ai raconté
l’Histoire de Newton, et je vous ai dit
que son plus grand éclair de génie, ce fut
quand il trouva une seule et unique explication
à la chute de la pomme et à l’orbite des
planètes.
Cette explication, c’est ce qu’il appela
la gravité.
Sauf que, pour Einstein, c’est faux.
La raison pour laquelle la pomme tombe par
Terre, c’est l’accélération vers le
haut du sol, alors que la raison pour laquelle
la Lune tourne autour de la Terre, c’est
à cause de la courbure de l’espace-temps.
Deux explications très différentes.
On est tentés de dire que l’une des deux,
voire les deux sont de la “gravité”.
Mais je pense que pour vraiment comprendre
Einstein, il faut s’interdire de parler
de gravité.
Il y a des référentiels en accélération
d’un côté qui expliquent la chute de la
pomme.
Et de l’autre, il y a la courbure de l’espace-temps
qui explique les orbites des planètes, et
le fait que la Terre ne grossit pas.
Thibaut Lescure trouve que j’insiste trop
sur le premier, à savoir le fait que le sol
accélère vers le haut.
Mais pour moi, cette idée toute bête, c’est
vraiment le plus important dans toute la théorie
d’Einstein.
Je parle à beaucoup de gens qui connaissent
le principe d’équivalence, et quand je
leur dis que le sol accélère vers le haut,
ils ne me croient pas.
Et je pense que c’est parce qu’on a trop
tendance à créer une distance entre la théorie
et la pratique, ou que les mots d’un principe
sonnent bien, mais on ne prend pas le temps
de vraiment les intérioriser.
Réfléchissez-y vraiment.
Je vous invite vraiment, à chaque fois que
vous sortez de chez vous, quand vous voyez
une feuille tomber, un oiseau voler ou des
gens jouer au foot, pensez au principe d’équivalence.
Dites-vous que dans tous ces phénomènes,
la “gravité” ne joue absolument aucun
rôle.
Tout s’explique uniquement par le fait que
le sol accélère vers le haut.
Il y a une superbe vidéo de PBS Space Time
là-dessus, où Gabe se demande si la gravité
ne serait pas qu’une illusion.
Ça fait titre putaclick, mais je pense pas
du tout que c’est putaclick.
Je cautionne Gabe à 200% quand il affirme
qu’il faut penser que la gravité n’est
qu’une illusion, et si vous ne vous êtes
pas arrivés à cette conclusion, c’est,
je pense, parce que vous n’avez pas assez
réfléchi au principe d’équivalence.
Moi personnellement, j’ai vraiment médité
ça pendant tout un mois, et je vous garantie
que ça a retourné ma vision de la réalité,
ça a fait explosé mon cerveau plusieurs
fois et ça m’a rendu heureux pendant tout
un mois.
Ce n’est vraiment pas pour rien que c’est
la pensée la plus heureuse d’Einstein.
Et je suis vraiment honnête quand je dis
que c’est l’une des plus heureuses pensées
que quiconque ait jamais eu.
C’est vraiment ça qui fait que je crois
toute la théorie d’Einstein, et c’est
pour ça qu’Einstein s’est dit qu’il
fallait refaire toute la théorie de la gravité.
Je pense sérieusement, que si vous comprenez
entièrement l’accélération vers le haut
du sol, vous comprenez 50% de la relativité
générale.
C’est pour ça que j’insiste dessus ! Et
puis, c’est une idée tellement simple…
Tout le monde peut y réfléchir !
C’est une idée qui soulève beaucoup de
questions, et vu le peu de questions que j’ai
eu à ce sujet, je suis persuadé que vous
n’y avez encore assez réfléchi.
Il y a quand même une très bonne question
de Malick qui demande quelle est la cause
de cette accélération.
Et pour répondre à cette question, il ne
faut pas oublier que la Terre, ce n’est
pas une bille immobile, c’est vraiment un
objet très dynamique, avec un coeur très
chaud, des remontées de magma et des mouvements
tectoniques.
La pression à l’intérieur de la Terre
est immense.
Rien que sous l’eau, et l’eau c’est
pas si lourd que ça comparé à la roche,
vous atteignez très vite des pressions qui
sont insurmontables pour l’homme.
Et bien, ce sont ces pressions immenses à
l’intérieur de la Terre, ou plutot le gradient
de pression, qui poussent la surface de la
Terre vers l’extérieur.
Et pourquoi y a-t-il de telles pressions à
l’intérieur de la Terre ? Et bien, parce
que la courbure de l’espace-temps rapproche
les trajectoires des atomes de la Terre vers
son centre.
Du coup, il y a beaucoup de matière au milieu
très écrasée, et ça, ça fait beaucoup
de pression.
Il y a d’autres très bonnes questions de
Tomate rouge, et je vais me concentrer sur
la question “Si la terre devient plus grosse,
les distances sont-elles toujours identiques”
? Et pour comprendre ce que je voulais dire,
je vous propose l’expérience de pensée
suivante.
Si je veux mesurer la Terre, je peux prendre
une règle super longue qui fait toute la
hauteur de la Terre.
Et si je veux savoir si la Terre grossit,
il me faut me demander si la règle va continuer
à mesurer la même hauteur de la Terre.
Et bien, là, la réponse dépend du matériau
de la règle.
Si les atomes de règles peuvent tranquillement
coulisser les uns le long des autres sans
interagir, alors les trajectoires de ces atomes
vont suivre des trajectoires en ligne droite
dans l’espace-temps, et se rapprocher les
uns des autres.
Dans ce cas, en fait, les atomes de la règle
sont en fait coller à l’espace, qui lui
rétrécit.
La règle va effectuer une mesurer de la taille
de la Terre plus grande que ce qu’elle n’était.
La Terre grandit donc par rapport à une telle
règle.
Cependant, si les atomes de la règle interagissent
et s’empêchent de se rapprocher les uns
des autres, ils vont alors résister à la
courbure de l’espace-temps, comme la Terre,
et à ce moment-là, vont mesurer une taille
de la Terre inchangée.
Je vous invite d’ailleurs à aller voir
cette excellente vidéo de Minute Physics
qui nous explique pourquoi, s’il est vrai
que l’univers tout entier grandit, nous
ne grandissons pas avec l’univers.
C’est à cause, comme pour la règle, des
forces non-gravitationnelles.
En fait, parler de la Terre tout entier, c’est
assez difficile, parce qu’il s’agit d’un
objet de grande taille.
Les référentiels en chute libre autour de
la Terre, ne restent pas parallèles.
Ils finissent par différer.
Et ça, ça revient à dire qu’il n’y
a pas de référentiel global dans les espaces-temps
courbes.
Plus général, en géométrie des espaces
courbes, il est très difficile d’avoir
une vision globale de ces espaces.
C’est pour ça que dans l’épisode 11,
je vous ai invité à suivre ma trajectoire
le long de mon vol Toronto Pékin seulement,
et que, dans l’épisode 12, je vous ai invité
à suivre la trajectoire de la balle de golf
seulement.
Les référentiels ne sont valables que localement,
sur des petits bouts d’espaces-temps.
Pareil pour le principe d’équivalence.
Il ne permet de penser que la “gravité”,
ou plutôt, la force d’inertie d’entraînement,
que localement.
Pour parler des liens entre des référentiels
éloignés à travers l’espace et le temps,
il nous faut calculer des courbures d’espace-temps.
Et ce n’est que sur de très grandes distances
d’espace et de temps que ces courbures d’espace-temps
ont un rôle à jouer.
En fait, ça va me permettre d’enfoncer
le clou sur l’erreur récurrente qui consiste
à dire que la courbure de l’espace-temps
explique la chute de la pomme.
Ça ne l’explique pas.
Oublions tout à coup toutes les forces non
gravitationnelles.
On peut alors se demander si la pomme tomberait
toujours vers le sol.
La réponse est en fait non ! C’est l’inverse
que l’on observerait.
La pomme s’éloignerait très légèrement
du sol.
Vous avez bien entendu.
La courbure de l’espace-temps éloigne la
pomme du sol.
Et je n’ai même pas besoin d’Einstein
pour vous expliquer pourquoi.
En physique Newtonienne, la force de gravité
décroît en 1/r^2.
Comme le sol
est plus proche du centre de la Terre que
la pomme, l’accélération du sol vers le
centre de la Terre est en fait plus grande
que celle de la pomme.
Du coup, la gravité éloigne la pomme du
sol !
Alors, rassurez-vous, cette éloignement est
incroyablement lent.
L’accélération avec laquelle le sol s’éloigne
de la pomme est de
6 millionièmes de mètres par seconde carrée.
Et ça, ça devrait vous aider à comprendre
ce que beaucoup
de vulgarisateurs sous-entendent quand ils
disent que la gravité est incroyablement
faible comparée aux autres forces de la nature.
À tel point que, à notre échelle, il est
très juste de considérer qu’elle n’existe
purement et simplement pas.
Encore une fois, dans nos vies quotidiennes,
il n’y a pas de gravité.
Il n’y a que
des forces électromagnétiques qui font que
des atomes trop proches se repoussent, et
qui, à travers
des
forces
de pression, accélèrent le
sol
vers le haut…